[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction
l'essentiel de l'actualité de ce 2
février avec les titres tout d'abord en
images un centre ahead d'éducation
piloté par l'association nationale pour
la formation automobile va ouvrir à
guyancourt un véritable campus que nous
vous présenterons au cours de cette
édition le vendée globe et l'arrivée de
l'illinois
louis burton et le termine à la 7e place
c'était dans le courant de la nuit les
premières images à découvrir et puis le
département des yvelines lance
l'opération adoptez un poilu initiatives
insolites pour aider les archives
départementales a retracé le parcours
des combattants de la grande guerre dans
l actualité la rencontre entre le député
yvelinois dorénavant en course pour la
présidentielle pour le parti socialiste
benoît hamon avec françois hollande elle
les deux hommes ont échangé pendant une
heure ce jeudi matin à l'elysée durant
ce face-à-face l'actuel président de
l'ua donner aucun conseil pour la
campagne a affirmé benoît hamon
le candidat qui a également opéré un
premier rapprochement avec les frondeurs
puisque maintenant c'est lui qui est en
position de rassembleur il a évoqué lors
de son discours ce matin les acquis du
et quinquennat mais il a précisé se
tourner uniquement vers l'avenir modem
et udf blégent main dans la main les
deux formations se réunissaient en début
de semaine ils ont réuni leurs militants
respectifs pour afficher une image
d'unité une réunion et qui ne va pas
sans poser de questions autour des
prochaines échéances électorales soutien
d'alain juppé le modem avait pris ses
distances à l'issue de la primaire de la
droite pour laisser planer le doute
d'une candidature de françois bayrou
du côté de lui dès la désignation de
françois fillon avait aussi entraîné une
division au sein des militants dans les
yvelines les deux formations ont donc
décidé d'officialiser leur rapprochement
ce début d'année autour d'une cérémonie
de voeux commune au niveau local on
ah vraiment pas le plus souvent une
feuille de papier à cigarette
d'épaisseur entre nos convictions et le
point de vue qu'on a sur les différents
projets locaux départementaux régionaux
et communaux bien sûr ça fait longtemps
qu'on se dit quand même qu'on a toutes
ces valeurs qu'on a en commun il
faudrait qu'on les porte sur le
territoire c'est vraiment pour le
territoire pour le fait parce que la
politique voyez bien la politique au
niveau national ça commence à devenir un
peu délétère il ya des affaires qui
sortent les uns les unes derrière les
autres europe et environnement l'heure
est donc à l'union avec des valeurs
communes et pourquoi pas un
rassemblement autour d'un autre candidat
pour la présidentielle et de macron
séduit c'est dû beaucoup y compris dans
nos grands faut pas non plus faire de
langue de bois pour autant
voilà il ya une méthode à l'évidence qui
est intéressante mais il ya un contenu
que qui est encore imprécis à l'évidence
donc on va voir ce qu'ils proposent
s'interpellent c'est intéressant
les jeunes ne suivent il a amené un vent
nouveau de l'air frais donc on peut pas
faire comme s'il n'existait pas c'est
pas possible et pourquoi pas des
candidatures communes aux législatives
une question que doivent évidemment se
poser les responsables des mouvements
lors des européennes de 2014 les listes
udi modem avait totalisé 14 % dans les
yvelines
derrière l'ump et le fn mais devant le
parti socialiste on quitte la politique
pour un mot du vendée globe à présent le
rambo little louis burton a franchi ce
jeudi matin à 8h47 précise la ligne
d'arrivée aux sables d'olonne
il termine donc à la 7e place sur cette
édition est le skipper bureau vallée a
bouclé son tour du monde en solitaire et
sans escale pour la première fois en 87
jours 21h45 vitesse moyenne 13 mieux on
écoute la première réaction du
navigateur à son arrivée
pas vraiment mon temps d'écrire sage je
m'attendais à ça on m'avait dit que ça
serait très fort je m'attendais pas
débouler à 20 noeuds sur la ligne arrivé
avec du vent comme ça + d'élise sur le
moteur donc toute la rentrée là c'est
rock'n'roll et surtout c'est de voir
autant de monde autant de monde d'un
coup au bout de trois mois de solitude
c'est un vrai vrai bonheur en fait
félicitations à l'illinois pour ce
vendée globe
guyancourt plus que jamais tourné vers
l'automobile après le technocentre
renault qui est implantée sur la commune
depuis 1998 c'est un campus qui est en
train de voir le jour sur plus de 5
hectares de superficie un centre de
formation d'éducation piloté par
l'association nationale pour la
formation automobile
la première pierre a été posée en
décembre dernier douze mille mètres
carrés de bâtiments une dizaine
d'ateliers et plusieurs laboratoires 7 à
guyancourt que le campus des services de
l'automobile et de la mobilité est en
train de se construire
il pourra accueillir jusqu'à 1000
personnes en formation
le campus des services de l'automobile
et de la mobilité aura pour objectif de
répondre à une carence qui existaient
regarder des andes des enquêtes et des
études qui ont été conduites il y avait
vraiment un manque de formation sur
l'ouest francilien
donc c'est vrai que ça fait plusieurs
années qu'on réfléchisse à la manière de
répondre à ceux à ce besoin
il ya une opportunité une carence
notamment marquée par une baisse de 16%
du nombre de jeunes en formation en dix
ans le nombre d'étudiants diplômés d'un
ca paix est passé lui de 76% en 2001 à
33 % en 2011
ce campus proposera des formations du
ceap et au diplôme d'ingénieur vous avez
les gènes qui vont rencontrer qui vont
pouvoir en fait voir toute la continuité
et les débouchés ou autres diplômes
possible jusqu'à la formation continue
parce que ça va leur permettre de voir
en situe en fait
ensuite dans un garage dans une
concession ce que ça peut donner en
termes techniques en termes comme en
termes de commerce ou en termes de ses
passes 2 d'innovation autour de tout ça
pour nos métiers
la première rentrée est prévue pour
septembre 2018
des journées portes ouvertes auront lieu
en mars de la même année
nous continuons cette édition du journal
de ce 2 février et depuis peu la commune
de magny les hameaux qui investit dans
une chaudière à bois pour son c'est tmc
le centre technique municipal
c'est un dispositif qui permet de
fournir du chauffage dans les
différentes structures de la commune
c'est un véritable défi écologique
mélanie poquet patrick jacques de
dixmude et mathilde demi inauguré depuis
fin novembre 2016 la chaudière à bois de
magny les hameaux prend place au centre
technique municipal et remplace un
équipement déguste une solution biomasse
qui réduit à 81 7% l'émission de co2 et
si on avait une
une chaufferie fuel qui était vieille
qui étaient vétustes énergivores et dans
le cadre de l'appel d'offres nous avons
fait cette proposition là d'abord pour
atteindre plusieurs objectifs faire des
économies d'énergie baisser les
émissions du co2 est ensuite avoir une
chaufferie qui est neuf qui peut durer
dans des rénovations énergétiques qui
permettent à la commune de magny les
hameaux de faire quelques économies
notamment en énergie
cette nouvelle chaudière et parmi eux 15
% de consommation énergétique
qu'auparavant la chaudière serre par
rapport aux justement à tous qui
chauffage sur le lieu principalement et
ça nous permet donc d'économiser ses
fameux 15% en énergie ça nous permet
aussi mais c'est pas forcément peut-être
l'élément essentiel mais c'est toujours
ça de pris
environ 3 % d'économie financière aussi
sur l'ensemble du fonctionnement
on fera un bilan sur justement les
économies d'énergie qui qui sont
signalés mais j'ai vraiment pas
d'inquiétude là-dessus
une innovation qui sert
d'expérimentation dans le parc naturel
et permettra de dresser un bilan sur le
long terme
ce jeudi 2 février c'est la ville de
bois d'arcy qui a accueilli la cérémonie
des villes et des villages fleuris des
yvelines une soixantaine de communes
pour recevoir ce label parmi elles
trappe qui a obtenu quatre pétales
maurepas et plaisir cinq pétales la
région a couronné magny les hameaux
aiguille en cours de leur première fleur
écouter bruno tout rond c'est l'un des
responsables de l'entretien des espaces
extérieurs sur la commune de guyancourt
justement c'est une volonté municipale
et puis donc une fierté de la part des
jardiniers des services afférents la
propreté la voirie le domaine public
mais ça demande un travail en amont
évidemment
il faut il faut se préparer dans la
propreté de mobilier urbain tout ce qui
est développement durable aux
réalisations des déchets et puis les
économies aussi en eau très important en
jury est très sensible à ça et nous
aussi d'ailleurs parce qu'on est dans le
move c'est l'époque qui veut ça depuis
novembre dernier les archives
départementales proposent un tout
nouveau dispositif adopté un poilu nous
en parlions en titre l'objectif c'est de
retracer le parcours de ces poilus de
ses combattants et de transmettre le
devoir de mémoire aux générations
futures mélanie poké mathilde et demi et
si vous êtes obtient poilus morts pour
la france prisonniers blessés ou
déserteurs les yvelinois se penche sur
le profil des soldats de la guerre et
renseigne leur fiche matricule indexer
ces fiches c'est à dire adopter en poids
lui quand on a un index une fiche on va
adopter un poilu et ses fiches
contiennent des informations très
variées vous avez bien sûr le parcours
militaire du soldat mais vous avez aussi
des éléments sur son état civil sur sa
description physique sur ses blessures
ses médailles aujourd'hui sur les deux
cent dix neuf mille fish a indexé plus
de 17000 ont été remplis par des
volontaires
un progrès pour les archives mais aussi
un devoir de mémoire pour faire revivre
localement l'histoire qu'on va
s'intéresser à à des hommes on va
vraiment faire revivre la mémoire de ces
soldats
il ne s'agit plus simplement
d'une masse comme ça tout à fait anonyme
mais en s'intéressant à ces fiches
matricule
on va vraiment s'intéresser au parcours
de chacun et faire revivre la mémoire de
chaque de chaque soldat assis derrière
son écran
michel renard a adopté son poids lui
depuis cinq semaines
il a déjà recensé plus de 2500 fiche
matricule une passion qui lui permet de
retracer son arbre généalogique
je suis tombé sur le frère de mon
arrière grand mère est donc et puis il
ya beaucoup de noms qui dont j'ai
entendu parler par mon grand-père ou
même de personnes ou de descendants de
ces gens là que j'ai connu les archives
départementales estime que le projet
aboutira en 2018 un cycle tout juste
après la fin de la première guerre
mondiale culture avec le festival
odyssée en yvelines c'est un festival
qui au niveau elle nationale se place en
première place des producteurs de
spectacles en direction de l'enfance et
de la jeunesse le conseil départemental
subventionne l'édition 2018 à hauteur de
3 128 mille euros le sujet de maxime le
maine je vois dans un peu moins d'un an
les créations de ces artistes
émerveilleront les spectateurs du 11e
odyssée en yvelines mais tournons 200
dates dans l'ensemble du département
donc notre objectif est de rayonner de
couvrir le département dans ses
spécificités notamment la réalité
évidemment en épousant les missions
relatives au champ du social
la particularité de cette édition 2010 8
c'est l'implication des territoires
d'action départementale ils
contribueront notamment à la
programmation et au bon accueil des
représentations et des résidences en va
en fait et c'est rodez
des salons ça peut être par exemple dans
les pmi pour pour l'accueil des pièces
et aussi pouvoir toucher un public qui a
un petit peu différent ce qu'on appelle
le public empêcher c'est donc les gens
qui n'ont pas l'habitude d'aller vers le
théâtre des conditions propices à la
création d'oeuvres originales l'art ça
peut pas se faire en séries on fait un
spectacle à un certain moment donné
à une certaine époque pour un certain
lieu et et après on essaie que
s'attendent à l'universel
six spectacles seront élaborées au cours
de l'année 2010 est chacun des
territoires d'action départementale
pourra ainsi en accueillir un en
exclusivité à l'occasion de l'ouverture
de la biennale en janvier c'est en fait
si festival dans le festival
sur le plan national le festival est le
premier producteur de spectacles en
direction de l'enfance et de la jeunesse
le conseil départemental le subventionne
à hauteur de 3 128 mille euros c'est la
fin de ce journal demain vendredi vous
avez rendez vous avec nicolas
kirillovitch pour une nouvelle édition
du 7 8 l'hebdo avec son invité fil rouge
pour commenter l'actualité tout
l'airplay les replays de nos émissions
et de nos reportages sont à découvrir
sur notre site internet très belle
soirée
[Musique]